NX bowling Prodigy with a rubber hand
and a now faceless Terrace back from the
dead these iconic characters and more
are on their way back to a screen near
you
it's time for a new generation of kids
to worry about shooting their eyes out
several decades after the classic
holiday film A Christmas Story was first
released sequel is in the works A
Christmas Story Christmas will bring
back Peter Billingsley as Ralphie the
elementary school age protagonist of the
first film now all grown up and facing
holidays yet again also returning for
the sequel are Ian Petrella as Ralphie's
brother Randy along with Zach Ward Scott
Schwartz and Artie Robb as Ralphie's
Trio of friends from school the story
follows Ralphie's return to his
childhood home in an attempt to give his
children a Christmas like the ones he
experienced as a kid according to
deadline Ralphie reconnects with
childhood friends reconciles the passing
of his old man and sows the seeds for
the origins of the Beloved holiday
classic A Christmas Story Christmas hits
HBO Max on November 17 2022 and is
directed by Clay cadis and written by
Nick schenk in 2020 Disney confirmed
that a fifth installment to the iconic
Indiana Jones franchise is on its way
once again starring Indy himself
Harrison Ford at 78 years old Ford will
likely retire his trademark whip in
Fedora by the end of Indiana Jones 5.
although the studio hasn't indicated
whether he'll pass the Baton to a
younger generation or close out the
franchise you show up every day you do
your job and then
they just let you go we do know that
he'll be joined in his Adventure by
Phoebe Waller Bridge of fleabag Fame
playing indie's goddaughter Helena Mass
Mickelson from Hannibal will play the
villain he'll be joined by Oscar nominee
Antonio Banderas and John Reese Davies
will again play indie's trusted
companion Salah in the director's chair
for Indiana Jones 5 is James Mangold
Mangold directed 2017's Logan which
serves as the send-off for Hugh
Jackman's Wolverine and Patrick
Stewart's Charles Xavier Logan offered a
thrilling and satisfying ending for
Jackman and Stewart's characters and
earned Mangold and Academy Award
nomination for best adapted screenplay
while Indiana Jones 5 isn't likely to
skew his dark as Logan we hope to
farewell to our favorite archeology
Professor will be just as moving when
the film hits theaters on June 30th 2023
in the age of sequels remakes and
reboots of what feels like every
significant film ever made revisiting
one of Cinema's most iconic horror
movies was inevitable sure enough The
Exorcist 2 3 and 4 are in the works from
Fright Factory blumhouse the original
Exorcist centers on a 12 year old girl
played by Linda Blair who's possessed by
a terrifying demon her mother played by
Ellen Burston hires a pair of priests
played by Jason Miller and Max von Sito
to perform an exorcism spoiler alerts
both priests died in the original film
and Miller and Von Sito have since
passed on as well but burst in will be
returning to assist a new protagonist
Leslie Odom Jr as he seeks help for his
own possessed child
the first film in the new Exorcist
Trilogy will be released in theaters on
October 13 2023 although there's a
possibility the following two films
could premiere on peacock
as far as bizarre action movie premises
go it doesn't get much weirder than
Face-Off in this bizarre Blockbuster
Nicholas Cage and John Travolta Star as
a terrorist and an FBI agent
respectively who literally swap faces
via a gnarly surgery in order to each
take each other's place even though
spoiler alert Cage's villainous Caster
Troy is killed at the end of the first
film a direct sequel is now in the works
from filmmakers Adam Wingard and Simon
Barrett Baron Wingard were quick to
clarify on social media that they have
no intention of reimagining the original
which Wingard considers a perfect action
movie speaking to the Associated Press
cage expressed enthusiasm at the
possibility of reprising his role in the
sequel saying I would love to get back
into that character and to work with
Travolta I miss that face
[Music]
when guard has expressed interest in
seeing cage return telling Empire online
he's just having such a moment a couple
of years ago the studio maybe would have
wanted a hot young up-and-coming actor
or something now Nicholas Cage is one of
the hottest actors in Hollywood again of
course says Cage's character is dead
it'll be interesting to see how they
bring him back but in a world as crazy
as Face-Off Anything is Possible
on his 35th birthday Julius Benedict
played by Arnold Schwarzenegger
discovered he was separated at Birth
from his twin brother Vincent played by
Danny DeVito after they were conceived
in a lab as part of a genetic experiment
twins followed the unlikely Duo as they
reconnected and uncovered the secrets of
their past 33 years later the Benedict
Clan is expanding once again in triplets
this time Schwarzenegger and Davido will
be joined by Tracy Morgan as a yet
unnamed third brother twins director
Ivan Reitman was slated to direct the
sequel until his death in 2022 and
describing the sequel Reitman told
deadline they don't know each other and
very early in the movie they meet it's
how they achieve a bond together after
all these years it's really a film about
family and no matter how different we
all are we have to learn to get along
originally the film was set to begin
shooting in 2022 from a script penned by
Dylan Dawson and Lucas kavner without
Reitman at the helm we wouldn't be
surprised if production gets pushed back
it was just a matter of time before the
bizarre 1988 Tim Burton haunted house
comedy Beetlejuice got the sequel
treatment sure enough Beetlejuice 2 is
finally in the works from Brad Pitt's
production company Plan B with Michael
Keaton and Winona Ryder expected to
reprise their roles from the first film
Beetlejuice starred Keaton as the
titular malevolent Spirit hired by
deceased couple Adam and Barbara
Maitland to rid their former home of its
living inhabitants
however nothing goes according to plan
Lydia Deeds the new homeowner's quirky
teenage daughter played by Ryder only
narrowly escapes being married off to
him by the end of the film The dietzes
and the maitlands are happily
cohabitating with Beetlejuice banished
to a waiting room for the non-living
although the script for Beetlejuice 2
hasn't yet been written we imagine it
will find him finally returning to find
Lydia all grown up how his path will
cross with that of his reluctant
ex-fiancee as currently anyone's gas
directed by the one and only John
Carpenter the 1986 fantasy Adventure Big
Trouble in Little China follows trucker
Jack Burton played by Kurt Russell as
he's drawn into the mystical underbelly
of San Francisco's Chinatown hoping to
save a kidnapped woman from the forces
of Darkness Burton encounters ninjas
monsters and an ancient sorcerer with
its Mythic Warriors and magical sword
fights Big Trouble in Little China has
become a classic so naturally people
were concerned when a remake with Dwayne
Johnson was announced in 2015. as it
turns out however the next film will
actually be a sequel speaking to
collider producer Hiram Garcia admitted
he can't remake a classic like big
trouble so what we're planning to do is
continue the story we're going to
continue the universe of Big Trouble in
Little China Garcia went on to explain
that the events of the first film will
still exist in the new Dwayne Johnson
movie but the rock will be playing a
brand new character while that leaves
room for Russell's return the actor said
that he probably won't be in the sequel
fans will definitely miss seeing Jack
Burton back in action
we thought the day would never come but
it looks like Ridley Scots is heading
back to ancient Rome
had my signal
unleash hell
nearly 20 years after the original
Gladiator hit theaters Scott is finally
making a sequel to The Story of Maximus
Decimus Meridius of course Maximus is
busy walking through wheat fields and
Heavens so what's the sequel going to be
about according to producer Walter F
Parks the film starts 25 to 30 years
after the original ended and according
to the Hollywood Reporter part 2 will
focus on Lucius the son of maximus's Old
Flame Lucilla it does sound like Connie
Nielsen who played Lucilla could come
back speaking to collider Nielsen said
that the sequel was still planned and
when asked if she would be willing to
return to the role she said it would
obviously be amazing and I know that a
lot of people want to see more of that
Scott revealed in late 2021 that the
script is already complete and Gladiator
2 is queued up to be the director's next
project once he's finished with Napoleon
with Scott at the helm we're pretty sure
we'll be entertained
fans of the 1996 bowling comedy Kingpin
are in luck because the sequel was
rolling down the pipeline the original
film featured Woody Harrelson as a
former bowling Prodigy who believes he's
found his meal ticket when he discovers
an Amish bowling Superstar played by
Randy Quaid 14 karat gold really
looks like rubber
no the ring not the hand the film also
starred Bill Murray as Harrelson's
lifelong rival as well as Vanessa Angel
Chris Elliott and Lynn Shane no details
have yet been revealed about the sequel
other than that Peter and Bobby Farrelly
who directed the first film will be back
on board to produce Kingpin 2. however
it's unclear whether the Farrelly
brothers are intending to write or
direct the sequel in addition to their
producing duties similarly none of the
original cast is confirmed to be
returning although fans would surely
welcome another chance to see Harrelson
and Murray together on the big screen
Jim Henson's cult classic Labyrinth has
a die-hard following thanks to its
creepily Fantastical storytelling
imaginative creature creations and of
course an iconic performance from David
Bowie as Jared the Goblin King I wish
the Goblins would come and take you away
making a sequel to Henson's final
feature film is a pretty intimidating
task but the Jim Henson company feels up
to it news of the labyrinth sequel first
broke in 2017 with don't breathe
filmmaker fide Alvarez attached to
direct however Alvarez announced in
April of 2020 that he was stepping away
from the film he told Bloody Disgusting
I just decided I didn't want to do
things as a director that people knew
already what it was or have a
preconceived notion of how it should
look on the screen so Labyrinth would be
something that people would judge that
way so I decided not to do it
fortunately the project didn't stay
rudderless for long in May of 2020
deadline reported that Dr Strange
director Scott Derrickson had stepped in
to helm the highly anticipated sequel
Maggie Levine the writer and director of
into the dark will write the screenplay
we don't have any details about the
plots but back when Alvarez was attached
project insiders confirmed to The
Hollywood Reporter that the sequel would
be a continuation of the story that
began in the original film as Bowie is
passed on however the Goblin King will
not be making an appearance
the first Lethal Weapon hit theaters in
1987 introducing audiences to the buddy
cop Duo of Riggs played by Mel Gibson
and Murtaugh played by Danny Glover
since then it spawned three sequels and
a television series however with no new
Lethal Weapon film since Lethal Weapon 4
in 1998 it was a surprise to learn that
Warner Brothers intended to reinvigorate
the franchise with a new entry prior to
the death of acclaimed director Richard
Donner who directed the first Ford
Lethal Weapon films in addition to
Superman and The Goonies producer Dan
Lin said the fifth film was particularly
special to Donner who was attached to
direct in 2020 Lynn told The Hollywood
Reporter we're trying to make the last
leap the weapon movie Donner's coming
back the original cast is coming back
and it's just amazing the story itself
is very personal to him and to the cast
and so I really want to make that one of
course none of that may pan out as
Donner passed away in 2021 however in
the wake of the filmmaker's death Mel
Gibson has confirmed that he is in talks
to take over directorial duties although
a deal has not yet been reached
it's been almost 20 years since
audiences followed effervescent Sorority
Girl L Woods the Harvard Law School and
the bubble gumed Legally Blonde she
continued to ascend the professional
ladder in 2003's Legally Blonde two red
white and blonde which saw L head to
Washington DC
now L is back along with producer Mark
Platt and Platt Productions president
Adam Siegel in addition to playing L
Reese Witherspoon is producing through
her hello sunshine Banner she's brought
on never have I ever created Mandy
Kaling and Brooklyn 99 Creator Dan Gore
to Penn the screenplay also returning
for the sequel is Jennifer Coolidge who
starred in both previous films as Elle's
friend Paulette I love snow globes
Shin there will be a lot of new faces in
Legally Blonde 3 and a lot more
diversity Kaling told E online
reflecting the world as it is now is
something that's really important to
Reese and so having there be like
diversity is super super important you
can definitely count on that a fan of
the original film Kaling is looking
forward to revisiting an older and wiser
and likely even more fabulous L Woods in
an interview with Access Hollywood she
said I can't wait to see what L Woods
what people will think of the way we
wrote L Woods at 40. how Elwoods is at
40 versus how she was at 21 has been
really fun to imagine but for those who
worry that Al may have outgrown the bend
and snap Kaling reassured fans bend and
snap is forever we definitely have a lot
of fan favorites from the original movie
despite nearly four decades having
passed since the Last Starfighter first
wowed audiences the time may be ideal
for a sequel Starfighter is about a
teenager who beats a video game only to
discover that the game is really a
recruiting tool looking for soldiers to
fight an Interstellar Alien War I've
seen him come and I've seen him go but
you're the best my boy dazzling light
years ahead of the competition which is
why Centauri is Here video games have
changed a lot since then which presents
an interesting way to continue the story
speaking to movie hole Jonathan battool
the writer of the original film said of
the sequel It's not a remake it's going
to continue the story what's changed
this time itself certainly as a video
world and the alien world have continued
to tick away it's not a time capsule of
the 80s by any means we're taking it to
the next level passing the torch or the
joystick but tool will be co-writing the
sequel titled the last starfighters with
Rogue one a Star Wars story screenwriter
Gary witta in March 2021 witta tweeted a
Sizzle reel that teases the plot of the
film from what we can gather the story
involves an alien attempting to
assassinate an adult Alex the
protagonist of the first film Alex then
heads off into space to get to the
bottom of things it's been a long road
but petul is optimistic the sequel will
finally get off the ground
the last National Treasure film hit
theaters back in 2007. in other words
it's been a long time since we've seen
Benjamin Franklin Gates treasure is a
myth
I refuse to believe that there have long
been rumors of a third National Treasure
film and while at times the project has
seem as lost as an ancient sash of gold
it looks like a new installment is
finally on the way in May 2022 producer
Jerry Bruckheimer confirmed the film is
in progress with a script by Bad Boys
for Livescribe Chris Bremner The Next
Step was to send the finished screenplay
to the original franchise star Nicolas
Cage the project is apparently still in
the works despite Disney moving forward
with Disney plus series National
Treasure edge of History
along with clerks 3 and other Kevin
Smith script that got polished during
the 2020 lockdown as the sequel to
1995's Mall Rats which depend under the
working title Twilight of the Mall Rats
the plot of the original film revolves
around a dating show being filmed at a
shopping mall and stars Jeremy London
Jason Lee Claire Fulani Shannon Doherty
Ben Affleck and Michael Rooker this time
instead of a game show the plot will
focus on a convention taking place at
the mall according to Smith the whole
thing is there's a big convention at the
mall so there's plenty of places and
opportunities for things to happen Smith
has revealed that the entire principle
cast of the first film will be appearing
in the second even confirmed that iconic
Comic Book Creator Stan Lee who passed
away in 2018 will have a scene to
parallel his cameo in the first movie
Smith confided to comicbook.com the
thing I feel most clever about in
regards to the movie obviously one of us
can't come back right Stan's gone so
there is a Stan Lee scene and it makes
absolute perfect sense joining the team
for Twilight in the Mall Rats is
newcomer aparna Brielle whom Smith says
will be at the center of the sequel he
tweeted I was so impressed with Brielle
I built my next flick around her a
partner will play Brody Bruce's daughter
Banner in the movie I hope to shoot next
Twilight to the Mall Rats Twilight of
the Mall Rats is likely to wind up as a
peacock exclusive release
it has been more than 30 years since we
last saw the fuzzy little nightmares who
shouldn't be fed after midnight when it
sounds like the Gremlins could be
returning to theaters in a new horrific
Adventure a sequel to the original movie
Gremlins 2 the new batch was released in
1990 original Gremlin screenwriter Chris
Columbus has apparently been working on
getting a third Gremlins off the ground
in November 2020 he told collider I
would love to do it I wrote a script
we're working out some rights issues
right now so we're just trying to figure
out when the best time to make that film
would be I would still do it the same
way I would do it as tangible puppets
not CGI
[Music]
the rights issues involve Warner
Brothers which owns the name and
franchise in greenlit and animated
Gremlin series for HBO Max called
Gremlins secrets of the Mogwai still
Gremlins director Joe Dante told slash
film I think it's inevitable the title
is too well known to not do something
with So eventually somebody's going to
do something with it which is fine as
long as there isn't too much CGI
RoboCop is back according to deadline
the cyborg is returning to the big
screen although it seems the new film is
going to mess with continuity the
original RoboCop was directed by Paul
verhoven and it made a killing when it
was released in 1987 after two sequels
in the early 90s the franchise was
rebooted in 2014 with actor Joel
Kinnaman and director Jose pajilia the
latest entry in the franchise will be
called RoboCop returns and will feature
a fresh cast in November 2019 Ryan
pitchers announced that little monsters
director a Forsyth had taken up the Helm
of Robocop Returns the screenplay was
originally written in 1998 by Ed
newmeyer and Michael minor the scribes
behind the first film with director
Forsyth giving in a rewrite newmeyer had
nothing but good things to say about the
new version telling sci-fi wire what he
came back with was really interesting it
felt relevant and really crackled
Dave Stevens 80s cult comic book The
Rocketeer clearly took inspiration from
mid-century movie matinee adventure
serials and in 1991 Banks came full
circle when Disney brought the story to
the big screen Billy Campbell starred as
Cliff Secord a 1930 stunt pilot living
in Los Angeles who finds a jet pack that
allows him to soar through the sky while
evading the FBI its inventor Howard
Hughes and the Nazis who want it badly
Disney thought it could launch a trilogy
but when the film underperformed at the
box office sequel plans were dead in
2020 the company started work on a
legacy style sequel to be titled the
return of The Rocketeer Now You See Me
screenwriter Ed rycort is writing the
film with actor David oyelowo producing
and possibly starring the upcoming
Rocketeer movie will follow a new
character a retired member of the famed
Tuskegee Airman who becomes the latest
pilot to strap on the Fantastic jet pack
while we don't know when it will be
released we do know it will land on
Disney Plus
we are in the midst of an Eddie Murphy
Renaissance after his Heyday in the 80s
and early 90s Murphy faded from the
spotlight he's suddenly back in a big
way giving a critically acclaimed
performance in 2019's dolomites is my
name making a triumphant return to
Saturday Night Live as host lining up a
new stand-up comedy special for Netflix
and announcing a sequel to one of his
biggest movie hits Beverly Hills Cop yes
you have a reservation for an Axel Foley
marking the fourth installment in the
Beverly Hills Cop franchise the latest
sequel will be a collaboration between
Murphy and Netflix since Paramount
pulled the plug on Beverly Hills Cop 4
back in 2016. Murphy will be back as
Axel Foley the Detroit cop who
repeatedly finds himself investigating
crimes in Beverly Hills directing will
be Mark Malloy a rising filmmaker who's
earned positive attention for his Apple
commercials Murphy has said he's ready
to go as soon as the script is complete
and will Beale best known for story
credits on Aquaman and Zack Snyder's
Justice League has taken on Beverly
Hills Cop Axel fully joining Murphy will
be Zola breakout star Taylor Page and
Veteran actors Joseph Gordon-Levitt and
Kevin Bacon addition Judge Reinhold
tweeted some photos in September 2022
that hint he'll return his Foley's
partner in crime fighting Detective
Billy Rosewood
after writing and directing the classic
indie horror movies The Evil Dead and
Evil Dead 2 but before he became the
a-lister behind the original Spider-Man
trilogy Sam Raimi ventured into the
superhero realm for the first time with
dark man it's a Dark comic book like
Revenge Thriller about a scientist who's
presumed dead but instead Don's a hat
trench coat and thick facial bandages to
take revenge on the bad guys who nearly
burned him to death oh yeah he's also
super strong and can create new faces
out of experimental skin but as
disguises are sensitive to light so they
never last long dark man was one of the
first big movies for future Superstar
Liam Neeson and three-time Oscar winner
Francis McDormand a couple of obscure
straight to video sequels to dark man
already exist Remy had nothing to do
with those and he'd love to revisit the
dark man World in 2022 he told the rap
that his sequel was in the extremely
early stages of development there's a
producer attached I haven't heard the
story yet or gone into it but I think
it's cool nothing in the way of creative
crew cast or release date has officially
been confirmed
[Music]
foreign
[Music]